hello again and welcome to Android
design in action I'm Roman Eric Adam
Kosh and Nick legit and today we're
going to talk about sleep monitor apps
well sleep monitor app and backward
compatibility we have a lot of content
to get through today so we're just going
to get started with sleep monitors so
the app that we just happen to look at
today was was sleep as Android it's
called sleep is Angela this is one of
the apps that was reviewed on the App
clinic last Friday by radio Meyer and
Nick took a look at this a pin in much
detail and and Nick do you want to jump
into your thoughts on sleep as Android
sure so sleeves Android is an
application that monitors your sleep and
lets you set my alarms they alway threw
up an opportune time when you're a very
kind of light sleep cycle and it's a
very detailed app you could if you take
a look at it L fit a whole ton of
functionality and configuration options
and you can see that the author is very
responsive to the communities instead
put out so like 15 update in the last
couple of months alone which is very
very responsive from a visual point of
view they have made some effort to kind
of get towards the kind of hollow and
design guidelines and but my overall
feeling of the application was that
while it's very very functional and
powerful I found it kind of hard to get
into and understand how to operate and
to prioritize what tasks are should be
doing first and what information was
important so if we take a look at the
application here this is the first
screen you see when you when you start
up this is that where you can create
different alarms as well as there's a
prompt unlock and some of the key
functionality on this feeling is is down
there on the bottom left I have kind of
like a split action bar but kind of not
a split action bar at the same time and
you can see some of the function access
to kind of add a new alarm start the
actual sleep tracking mode and to see
some statistics of you know your
previous previous night's sleep and so
soon too short for toilet or you go
straight into
and we hope to see what we cooked up so
here you can see we've done it's not a
huge departure but it's definitely kind
of we try to apply some of the hollow
look and feel to the application so
straight off there is a standard action
bar giving you that kind of sense of
where you are and a common place to look
for some of the actions and I felt like
we had to kind of reorganize some of the
functionality a little bit because this
main screen while I offered the alarms
and there's a lot of functionality kind
of hanging off sub screens as well and I
felt like this app has two main purposes
which is like setting alarm to wake at
the right time and for monitoring your
sleep and seeing kind of how that sleep
pattern and it's going so I wanted to
float those write it up as your primary
kind of options into these two main tab
settings it alarms and stats tab as you
can see we've also am really really kind
of emphasized the track and track sleep
button instead of just a little button
at the bottom with equal weighting to
all the other options it's now this
gigantic kind of purple button and
finally a little note on the on the
coloring and a palette I found some of
the kind of green highlights to be kind
of like grabbing your focus thing look
at me on the divider which kind of felt
slightly off to me so you kind of
redress the palate a little bit here and
it's taking quite a lot of cues from the
stock alarm clock in the latest version
of Android two reasons firstly i like it
i think is a beautiful up have might be
controversial and I've working say but
also this should be kind of its offering
slightly similar functionality so it's
helping to bootstrap these as mental
models a lot of thing kind of user
elements week user interface elements
reviews look the same as from the stock
alarm clock app so hope you can get
started this application bit quicker now
what 18 thing I wanted to mention about
the color scheme the kind of switched
from from the sky neon green to a neon
violet I guess it's really kind of it's
what I guess is the violet that's in the
Android design official color palette I
think that it just it's a little less in
your face it's still very much an accent
color it's not like you know a dull grey
or dull blue it's more muted but it's a
little easier on the eye
I think you can even probably go even
one shade darker if you want you know on
some devices you know it may be too
bright but I mean this is just like I
think it's just much easier to to look
at the screen and not be overwhelmed
immediately yeah one of the things I
want to say is like because this is one
of the last things you'll look at before
you go to sleep like you know to you're
about to go to bed you're going to hit
sleep you so normally this kind of a pie
will immediately for change it to a
light palette and foremost apps i think
a light palette is generally a good
starting point of this app globe because
you didn't want to have that that
feeling of you know you're leaving at
your bedside every turn your phone and
some of it you're kind of like blinded
by it an intensity so I've tried to keep
the tones quite mute to try and ease
that kind of transition ready now in
terms of navigation I like how you've
split stats and alarms into the sort of
top-level tabs there and removing it
from the you know the sort of faux split
action bar that was in the previous
version leaving the two main actions
that are visible there the track sleep
and the ad and it was a fun sorry go
ahead Nick I'd say I find a point like
on the before shot you can see there's a
little bugdroid figure in the bum corner
and his state changes depending on how
close it is to you having to go to bed
said white man and it's kind of the
daytime and he's got a little a
britton-fronted or whatever but as it
gets closer tonight he starts brushing
his teeth and so on well I think that's
useful and fun I do really like that I
do find sometimes including a bugdroid
in your application or even Android or
droid in your name of application kind
of lazy and amateurish she does every
select shout this is a fully
professional application I fought with
interaction and so I try to incorporate
the same elements using same difference
if you can see on the after shot very
subtly there's a number of kind of
sleepies it's kind of in the background
is it see application the idea here
being as you get closer to bedside and
develop more of them connect start kind
of coming out from the track seat button
or even you could happen subtly animates
in some way it's very very simple him
but it's trying to convey the same kind
of information but in a slightly more
kind of subtle way and we also did a job
on I'm changing the icon so we shifted
the icon
from being kind of a sleeping cute
bugdroid to something very generic this
is just a very rare generic icon but
again something that is a little more
recognizable and something that is a
little more unique to the app coop let's
fisher we got sure we move on to the
next screen yeah all right alrighty so
next up so the next step our next one of
the major functions i thought this
effort is is give you lots of
information about how you've been
sleeping almost too much information so
if we touch the graph like on the bottom
left you get to this sub screen screen
screen here with a number of options
here so we've picked out the start
screen here which can have a very very
long table and this is just a small
sampling of information because we have
me i hadn't been running the app for
very long if you look at the developers
screenshots on the place so you can see
this could be a massive table in a while
gives you some average stats it's kind
of summed up over all time now when I
kind of like try to redress this and
think what do I really care about I
probably only care about a kind of the
last week's stats like anything that's
old and that probably doesn't really
have much bearing on like kind of you
know how I feel my sleepings been going
what happened two months ago isn't
really relevant any longer so what I've
done with this screens have tried to
provide these some reset so the most
importance of thing to me is a summary
of this week how I've been doing for the
last kind of say seven days or whenever
the start the week in your calendar
starts from and so we pulled out some
summary statistics and those are big
involved and it uses color to signify
whether you are close to your target
average length of sleep per night or if
you're building up the sleep there so
here we can see we're using kind of
orange for okayish blue for yeah you
doing well or red forewarning you're not
kind of getting this sleep so instantly
when I look at this I can get this quick
scannable screen which tells me what's
going on here you can see that I Tuesday
you for some reason didn't sleep very
well maybe you were you know out out on
the town the night before or something
like that jiminy Christmas parties at
the moment
hello so we've consciously demoted a lot
of information so if you look at the
before there's other tabs for noise and
graphs that's all there's some kind of
store as well which didn't seem to kind
of be worthy of being a top level
information I thought it was kind of
like adding noise and making it harder
for me to realize what was really
important so we've really simplified it
down these few items and we let you kind
of roll the whole week up and down if
you want to turn it into a sari or drill
down into the each one we've restoring
these informations interesting for those
people who want it though so the idea
here is if you can tap on each of the
days you can then go forward into a
saucepan screen which is going to give
you details about that one nights and
sleepy attract cool so here ya on the
next slide yeah so on the next slide
instead of having this whole kind of
roll up over graphs and that that kind
of view of all the different day as a
graph didn't really tell me much I
didn't find that very glance but you
couldn't really look at it and say oh
that was a good night all that was a bad
night so but the grass themselves look
like or so we demoted them down to earth
detail screen so if you touched one of
each of the line items from the previous
screen and you get through to asleep
details will tell you you know how long
you actually slept for how long that was
in deep sleep what percentage and give
you those that kind of really nice graph
showing you exactly what the night was
like that's where there's a first
information can capture when you record
to sleep like a rating or a comment on
how good or bad it was so these are
really kind of like details which we
kind of change information architect and
hierarchy and kind of put these down to
a subsequent screen yeah I think it's
just a great job just I mean splitting
up the I guess a very very complex
screen a complex screen that you know
has good data but it's just not as easy
to consume and in showing you something
that's like you know letting you really
look at the content or one specific
piece of content right the specific day
and see all the details and I think it's
just like a good combination of
different types of pieces of the content
like a graph some averages and data like
that potentially know along these are to
provide a comment or
you know you've been providing a
recommendation like maybe you should you
know where you know where something or
sleep stellar who knows that I know
nothing about you know sleeping
medication anything with that but you're
giving the user all these different
types of components to their one night
of sleep is a really interesting and
unique way to present them personally I
really like the typography that you've
used here Nick on both your screen and
the other screen it just really brings
out the important information and plus
the coloring really helps helps you
glance at it and see what's going on
cool and this one final free design idea
we had this application and that's to
take advantage of a cool new feature in
android 4.2 called daydreams and that so
for those you who might not be aware
daydreams is it's kind of like a
screensaver functionality so you can set
up a daydream to say that when why and
my device is docked or charging kick
over into this canonical screensaver so
what I thought would be really really
cool is rather than having to manually
go into the application and start it to
track you sleeping it would be awesome
if just the fact that I guess most
people like me probably plug their phone
in at night as charging overnight and so
just doing that is enough to say kick
off a daydream which will then start
tracking your sleep and I imagine you
probably put some logic in there if it's
in the middle of the day or something
like this you wouldn't actually kick off
daydream but yeah just just the act of
plugging in the device and putting it
down on your bed could then kick off the
functionality so I really find anything
which means you know it's a bit of a
burden on the user to have to go into
this application every night and
remember to do it hit the start button
hit the stop button remember to do that
in the morning so anything you can do to
automate that process I think it's going
to make the user will regular they're
going to keep keep on using it and see
the value of replication so i thought id
daydream might be a cool way to do that
yeah it's just another way to step up
the the level of ur the feeling of magic
in this app where you know if you can
automatically track these things and do
it right so you know before say 9pm 10pm
if it turns on or or if your phone goes
idle
maybe you just show a clock or you know
it's fairly easy to just create a you
know a simple clock daydream that just
shows the current time in the kind of
date but then you know after a certain
point it kicks in to kind of tracking
mode and shows the clock and maybe even
maybe this is a way to you know play
like you know soothing sounds in the
background or something as you're
sleeping so since this app is already
doing all this data capture maybe you
can use that intelligently to even
improve your sleep as you're you know as
you're sleeping maybe by playing sounds
or something like that so lots of lots
of ideas here i think that the daydream
idea is really good here I think and of
course you can interact with daydreams
as well so I mean you could still have
something that you could touch and
resize all or potentially graphs during
the day that you could look at or
something like that all right so overall
a really nice app with lots of lots of
functionality I hope and the developer
like some of the ideas we've thrown
around there and perhaps tix runs with
them yeah and if you're watching for the
developer of this app and you're
watching that to you know let us
know what you think on google+ or where
you know even email or whatever but
definitely looking forward to you know
talk to me if you have any questions or
you want so ed azure even some of the
source PSD files already telling that if
we ever review your app or take a look
at your happen we do a mock-up if you
want the sources they're always
available no licensing issues whatever
we'll just hand them over to so and we
do we do it with love though I saw some
comments for our past redesign of tasker
saying is that a slap down from google
having been known to redesign your
office that's not what this show is
about this is about what what it could
be we'd love to kind of work with you to
help you kind of like get the best out
Android design that you can yeah and
almost all the apps we review their
awesome apps they're really just good
they're there you know fulfilling their
functions really well so
all right yes yes we should we got 15
minutes left need to fly through
backward compatibility so we have a lot
of slides and backward compatibility
fortunately a lot of them are
screenshots but let's get started so
before we talk about you know our
strategies and tips for backward
compatibility and specifically for
designing for backward compatibility not
so much for developing for that I mean
we have lots and lots of training
sessions and all that for developers but
this is really more targeted at
designers before we share some of our
own you know tips here I definitely make
sure that you know you guys your
designers out there are looking at the
design guidelines for compatibility the
the guidelines page for compatibility is
fairly you know fairly short it only
talks about a few important things some
of the things include you know the
legacy menu button how action overflow
behaves across different devices so it's
definitely stuff that you should be
aware of before you know jumping in too
much just close this video right now go
read it lil late thank you don't yeah we
do have a lot to cover so backward
compatibility so the way we view
backward compatibility is that for for
each screen in your app and you can
extend this to you know your entire app
or just an individual widget you know
for each screen visual styling and the
behavior basically visual and
interaction design can boil or can can
operate along a spectrum of of how close
it is to the the primary version of the
app so for example you know if I have an
ad design you know for android 4.1 plot
and above and I have you know hollow
elements in there on earlier versions on
your android 2.3 gingerbread froyo
whatever you can make a choice of either
you know taking that holo design or
you're completely custom design and and
using it on that device or you can kind
of say whatever the device default is
for example for checkboxes on
gingerbread they were green instead of
blue and some devices back then it was
like blue red or whatever you can make
the choice that you know I should use
the device default or you could just
choose something in the middle
so you know usually the the it's a
little harder to make everything hollow
back to Gingerbread and fry em it's very
very easy for developers to you know
just use the device default and then you
know this hybrid is kind of somewhere in
the middle so the hybrid solution it's
it's you have to be kind of careful
about it it can still really work and
we'll show you guys in the screenshots
coming up that you know hybrid UI is
where some components are Hollow and
some components are using the device
default styling they can work so we'll
show a couple of examples of those but
this is really how we see this kind of
the way you you decide on the back of a
paddleboat strategy right you you kind
of pics somewhere along the spectrum and
depending on where you choose now you
need to work with your developers on
this but depending on where you choose
that'll you know change the amount of
effort involved for developers and
certainly it'll it'll change the final
outcome but just be aware that you know
you know these are the different options
and there's really no correct choice i'd
say like i said before you can do it
correctly you can do it right using any
one of these different options it's
really up to you to make sure that it
just works well it's really just a
trade-off between these different
options like there's more effort
involved on the left side of the
spectrum but you'll have a more
consistent look on the right side it can
still work as will show you in the
screenshots shortly so a bit more effort
there's some tools LOL absolutely and
we'll talk about the tools out there
that are more relevant to developers and
designers but i'm still definitely their
stuff out there to help so having said
that hollowly a lot of people ask us new
is hollow for android 4.0 and above
right i mean like should I even try to
use hollow and earlier versions of the
platform and our answer is yes I mean
hollow is not designed just for the
latest devices out there hollows really
is designed for all people for all
humans it's really a it's a design
language for human-computer interaction
not just human android 4.0 plus
interaction you know it can work
everywhere
it obviously takes some effort to make
it work but again as a designer you need
to think of it less as the styling of
Android 4.0 and really as the identity
of Android so that's an important point
to make another is that you know the
core experience across all platforms
should really be consistent you
shouldn't really have to design an
entirely separate app for Gingerbread
and for ice cream sandwich so things
like the action bar you know those
should be visible and persistent across
all devices you shouldn't you know
switch into a completely different UI on
earlier versions just because there's no
built-in framework component and again
we'll talk about them so things like
layouts of the core layouts the
navigation like swiping between tabs and
the core interactions like the the basic
way you you know you choose you know
choose a contact for example those
should really behave the same across
different OS versions and I think that
you know for for design this is really
the last point is more about developers
but you know be opportunistic beyond the
core experience the core navigation look
really the core feel of the app you know
like the individual checkboxes and the
spinners and things like that you know
be opportunistic about it make sure that
nothing looks really bad obviously but
the opportunistic and don't you know put
yourself in the position where you must
have everything pixel perfect because
that's just a losing battle it's going
to take too much time and you're going
to kind of lose focus from what's really
important that is the core experience at
the app so before we go on any other
points guys but um
III know okay let's go salad let's go
let's do it another thing to mention
this is more on the tactical side so one
of the big differences and you'll see
this in screenshots between android 4.0
android 2.3 and such is the typography
is the font right so roboto is the
default on android 4.1 higher and droid
sans was the default everywhere else so
this is one area where you really
shouldn't try to just take Roboto and
use it everywhere on Android 2.3 the
reason being that you know users are
really accustomed to see like their eyes
almost expect to read text in a certain
way on on their device and so you should
really just use the system default font
the good thing is that for designers you
know when you're planning out the the
widths of your your elements and things
you have to think obviously you know how
many characters will fit in this line or
in this UI widget and the good thing is
that Roboto Android Santa's or metrics
compatible meaning that if you take the
same piece of text in Roboto Android
sand on android 2.3 device an Android
4.2 device you'll notice that there
they're pretty much the same with so
what's more important here is like
things like translations where you know
for example the German version or the
German strings for something will cause
things to be really really wide that's
more important to think about then like
just saying all I need to choose the
right font here so be be more aware of
that then just like the difference
between droid sans Roboto in English for
example and then also this is this is
again more for tactics but in your
process it's really important for
designers to participate in the device
testing process so you know usually
you'll have you know a QA team or maybe
a developer that has a whole bunch of
devices and they're kind of you know
testing the apks on all those devices
designers should really participate
because you know sometimes designers in
a team are some of the most kind of
visually sensitive folks so they'll be
able to you know pick out what the what
the in thick with the little quirks are
and so as a designer you should try to
you know introduce yourself into the QA
process and not obviously full time but
then some time making sure that you're
testing you know the output on earlier
versions of the platform as well as
different devices you just get a feel
for it looks like and there's a bunch of
continuous integration tools that you
know once you test your app on different
versions and will produce screenshots
and you can take a look at you know a
screenshot generated or older or smaller
device or something which will help you
and another this is something that make
you alluded to earlier but you know if a
developer comes to you as a designer and
says you know we can't do this
specifically why because it's only
available on you know honey comb it
above or android 4.2 and above you know
that's not always a great excuse because
there are great libraries out there that
solve this for them so you know don't
have to think that oh I need to design
an app with an action bar and a nap
without an action bar and a nap with
like you know all hollow components and
a nap with zero hollow components
because you know it's just not available
there are lots of libraries out there
that will help you here just a few so
actionbarsherlock I'm sure a lot of you
are familiar with that basically is a
almost like almost a hundred percent
like back port of the action bar to
previous versions of the platform how
everywhere actually gives you a lot of
the standard widget styling like
spinners and and text fields and such
and actually they do a lot more like
calendars calendar view and things like
that they give you a lot of this library
gives you a lot of stuff that you can
just back port to earlier versions so if
a developer comes to you and says you
know I absolutely cannot use the action
bar because it's not available on
earlier versions of the platform fight
that you know tell them that you know
you do have tools available to and maybe
there's no that's not the greatest
reason for not doing it so perform we
went to the screenshots any extra
thoughts parting wisdom for backward
compatibility strategy but all the
things okay but it's really you know
it's really up to you right as a
designer you should be aware of the
different types of devices out there be
aware of the tools that developers have
to them and make the right decision for
your app there's no question just a most
serious
I'd say that if you had infinite
resources you'd probably end up writing
a veggie wrap which six you know right
at home on Ice Cream Sandwich right at
home on gingerbread right at home on
froyo but given not everyone has the
resources to do that you kind of want to
put most of your effort into kind of
skating where the pucks going and like
designing for hollow and then I Roman
said to be opportunistic about back
pointing the finer pixel control stuff
like a where you have capacity all right
so in the interest of time since I think
our producer actually has to run in
exactly in about five minutes or so so
let's fly through some screenshots so
these all these screenshots are going to
be apps that kind of we feel do the
right thing and you're going to see that
it's a combination of that Universal
hollow everywhere kind of a pure device
default and somewhere in the middle so
this is this is tasks free this is both
the interactions and visuals on ginger
bread and jelly bean and you'll see that
throughout all these screenshots so this
is just their edit screen you'll notice
that they have hollow pretty much
everywhere holo styling everyone this is
the same tasks free and all these slides
will be available after and by the way
guys feel free to jump in as you see fit
but this is all just again another
example of apps that kind of have a pure
you know I guess a pure universal look
and feel here this is pattern another
app that there's a really good example
of how to do things like almost
perfectly replicated across ginger bread
and jelly bean and this is an example
the first example you see where there's
hybrid styling so the Play Store on
gingerbread uses kind of the standard
text field and a custom button style and
on ICS and above they use the hollow
text field styling and the hollow
actually I guess it's also a custom
button but again it works really well in
both cases there's no you know obvious
mismatch of components here
this is one minor case I wanted to point
out where almost everything here in
series guide is hollow except for the
little stars and so these stars here in
ginger butter green on ICS there they're
blue and really it doesn't again it
doesn't really detract from the
experience that it's it's sharing some
styling and it's I guess using what the
device has a default this is an example
of the i/o app where this is just one
minor screen where there's a mix of
styling this actually we need to improve
this for next year I think this could be
better but this is an example of you
know where it kind of works fairly well
but you know can be improved that's a
good example if what you're talking
about with a typography where the droid
sans looks quite a home on gingerbread
and the robot it looks right at home on
ICS and note all of these use droid sans
on gingerbread and Roboto on ICS another
quick example from the recipe search app
of text field and wife text yeoman right
this is this an example of using I think
it's from how about we which is an
online dating site where they use kind
of a mix of holo styling for Gingerbread
and indeed platform default styling and
it's really you know again it works okay
the core feel and experience in the app
is really you know maintained it's just
this one screen has kind of a mix of of
widgets filings so I think it's the
works quite well another example from
from how about we so this is another
case search where you know by default
the platform has is like built-in search
mechanism so if you use something called
search manager which is kind of
irrelevant for designers but the
platform default search looks a certain
way on gingerbread you should really try
to use that because your users are
really used to that whereas an jelly
bean there's another different type of
way to do it using something called
search view and the action bar that you
know that shows that same kind of
autocomplete stuff so it's really very
very similar the implementation slightly
different for developers but again it's
it's using what what users would
back you know standard extended platform
stuff in the left and the standard
action bar stuff on the right another
example of the Ted search view this is
old gingerbread Sally yep place oh and
this is an example differences with
references where preferences you
generally want to use you know the
system default styling you don't have
your own custom styling there so where
possible use you know the standard
preference activity preference fragment
and to do all that stuff for you and
that's like tasks which have generally
themed everything hollow style and their
preferences they still fall back on the
standard oh here we go yeah beat me to
it I'm same as a safe dead and then this
is a real quick to talk about contextual
actions Jeff if you have to go by all
means so contextual actions this is
something that's kind of controversial
like do you back port the contextual
action bar which is kind of I'd say a
minor interaction I think that's really
up to the developer if it's easy you
know then do it if not then don't do it
unless it's the core experience in your
app in this case you know for pattern
the core the core mechanic here is to
you know motto is to work with patterns
so you know allowing users to do
multiple selection on the patterns make
sense here but certainly you know it's
it's I think it's still secondary where
you can still perform these actions in
kind of a detail screen so don't feel
completely obligated to backport unit
contextual action bar I will say the
actionbarsherlock does this contextual
action bar back for it for you so yeah
something to keep in mind and then this
an example of the i/o app which chose
way in which we chose not to backport
the contextual action bar so here when
you long-press something you just get a
context menu which again is more
standard on earlier versions of the
platform another screen from pattern
where they've chosen the device default
styling for dialogues and they've
actually correctly flipped the positive
and negative actions in the dialog which
is
and then some more from the place or to
think that's the last one yes ok so
those backward compatibility obviously
we can't cover such a big topic and so
such a short period if you guys have
comments thoughts feel free to post
online and if there's anything we miss
we made you even touch on this some time
in a week Jewish solo che yeah for sure
what's the content yet but I fly through
design news since we have very little
time first Taylor as always has been
doing redesigns he's did a really cool
redesign on a movie ticketing app using
the wizard flow or the wizard pager
example that I pushed out a few weeks
ago it really cool this kind of custom
card style here for for the tikati
purchased vertical obviously we recently
launched the end official Android design
community on Google+ here's a couple of
examples of post there if you haven't
seen it yet I'd recommend joining lots
of good content coming up from there and
line this community really really like
quality of discussion going on in the
kitchen base and lastly Nick you want to
talk about the responsive headache
relief for Android slides yeah yeah this
is a really beautiful presentation i
highly encourage you to check this out
if you want a good summary or take the
temperature of web responsive design is
on android especially from a website at
this point of view really really and do
it a good presentation recommend it
awesome all right i think that's it for
the show thanks to everybody who tuned
in we will not see you next week this is
actually the last show of 2012 we will
see you sometime in 2013 thanks for
tuning in I'm Roman Eric I don't crush
by from Nick butcher have a great
holiday 0 happy holidays